hi I'm Erik Bosse and this is a
breakdown of the Walking Dead the season
8 premiere titled mercy it's great to be
back for Season 8 especially when things
kick off with such a literally explosive
episode seriously Michael Bay do this
one because Daryl made enough boobs to
blow up an asteroid and here at new rock
stars we like to dive deep into the
super subtle miscible details of the
visuals and the cultural influences and
yeah we're trying out this new live to
tape format to get these breakdowns to
you faster don't worry they'll still be
obsessively detailed but I no longer
have the luxury of an editor to remove
my awkward takes that's right I'm doing
this all in one take folks yeah see
normally an editor would have removed
that weird crap okay let's get started
with the big question that you guys were
asking us about after this episode or
hey tweeted us is old Rick a dream a
jump in the future and Brad tweeted us
seemed like we were seeing Rick at three
or more separate points this season yes
what is the deal with old man Rick and
why is this I'm so jumping around in
time well allow me to try to explain yes
this entire episode is out of sequence
bordering on disorienting the opening
image is of a teary-eyed mournful
looking Rick shortly after we see shots
of an older bearded Rick he walks with a
cane suggesting an injury he suffered
from a past war with negan but the
present timeline Rick is neither of
those two his story this episode begins
at the graves of Glen Abraham in the
hilltop and he proceeds into his battle
with negan but even then that battle
plan is something we dive right in the
middle of no expository planning scenes
no fashion montage is where they all try
on different color armbands
corresponding to their communities and
the final scene of the episode jumps
back into Rick's rousing speech which
seems to happen before the battle so I
think this timeline chaos is by design
this is meant to feel like the opening
charge of a battle something that is
both meticulously synchronized and
ultimately messy and disorienting
throughout the episode we get this tight
close-up of watches and clocks yet both
instances characters use those clocks
for a countdown Tara on the overpass
Rick outside the sanctuary giving them
from a countdown from 10 they both end
up saying screw the timing so that's the
thematic reason behind the timeline
stuff but what are we literally seeing I
personally don't think
those images of old man Rick are meant
to be taken literally notice the soft
dreamlike filter over these shots also
the bizarre song choice playing in the
scene a lot of you asked about that as
well and I'll have more thoughts on that
on how it all connects to the overall
theory later on so much of this episode
for Rick focuses on the idea tomorrow
tomorrow's a word on Daryl's love note
to Dwight tomorrow is what Maggie asks
Rick about so those images represent
that idea of tomorrow for Rick an ideal
happy ending future that keeps him
fighting now I could be wrong but I just
don't think this season premiere would
spoil all of these characters surviving
this all-out war to me the more
mysterious shot of Rick is this
teary-eyed one all we know about it is
that he said and he's standing under
this interesting stained glass he
actually has a similar look of despair
that he did in the opening shot of the
season 7 premiere right after Glenn and
Abraham had died so I interpret this as
the opposite of Rick's heaven dream it's
some alternate he'll future where this
war goes very very bad specifically I
think Rick is burying someone here so
I'm gonna get to some theories on who
but if you don't want to know skip to
this time that's right I conjured this
number of life fear me okay my first
theory is based on what Rick says may my
mercy prevail over my wrath this was
spoken earlier by the new mysterious guy
a new Muslim character apparently named
Abood though he could be adapted from
Sadiq in the comics I'm not sure if Rick
was close enough to hear him say this
mercy line he said that he heard most of
it but maybe Rick will form a
relationship with this guy and repeat
these words during his burial the second
theory is Gabriel Gabriel ended this
episode with negan and it could kind of
be fitting for Rick to use this verse
from the Quran to eulogize a holy man of
a different faith huh third theory Karl
now I know Karl seems like a lifetime
character the show would never kill off
maybe just shoot his eyes out but he
definitely did hear that guy say that
line and it's his actions this episode
showed that he was influenced by those
words snapping at his father to have
more mercy and there was that one
Lookout saber that Rick killed who
warned him that his family would die but
that leads me actually to my last theory
and I actually have a really strong
morbid suspicion that this could be the
case Judith a big part of the old Rick
dream shots focused on this relationship
with his daughter
appeared older and perfect angelic and I
think those were showing these butterfly
kisses future that Rick wanted the
opposite of what's happening now and fYI
Judith hadn't survived to this point in
the comics and toddler aged kids are
really hard for a TV show to work with
since they tend to noticeably age during
the six-month off seasons and would be
horrible to see this happen on the show
but I could imagine them doing it to
force Rick to pay a heavy emotional
price in this all-out war okay speaking
of the comics I'm gonna move on here to
a segment where it compared the shots
and events in this episode to the
version and Robert Kirkman source
material I call the super nerdy parts
well in the comics okay so the events of
this episode were adapted mostly from
issues 115 and 116 from The Walking Dead
comics Carl left behind to defend
Alexandria and Andrea whose arc has been
adapted to show non the show offers to
help Carl since now he's in charge also
we see Rick have a similar speech on the
back of a truck he fires a warning shot
to get negan's attention though in this
case they made this cool change so that
they all fire together also a lot of
negan and Rick's back and forth is kept
the same as well as Gregory's betrayal
and negan egging him on with the word
and before kicking him off the platform
and the battle goes pretty much the same
way too with Rick's people shooting out
the sanctuary windows and luring the
walkers to box them in though in the
comics a truck just knocks down the
fence instead of also exploding because
why not
vegans final line of the episode the
hope you got your [ __ ] pants on is
also something directly from the comics
and if those shots of old man Rick
aren't a dream if they're the actual
future some comic readers have suggested
that this festival that they're prepping
for could be a version of a major event
from way later in the comics which I
won't get into other than to say it
involves a group called the whisperers
and something crazy happens okay moving
on this episode was the 100th episode of
The Walking Dead which is a huge
milestone for any TV show and the
writers said that they celebrated this
partly by sneaking in a few callbacks to
the very first episode of the series and
I'm gonna run through these and all the
connections to past episode it's in a
segment called callbacks yeah I know
it's a little on the nose okay so first
another reason I'm thinking old man Rick
is a dream vision not literal reality is
that the shot of him wake
up and looking over at the flowers is a
direct call back to Rick waking up from
the coma in the pilot looking over at
the dead wilted flowers I think all this
imagery is meant to be a surreal
opposite of Rick's reality and this
scene with Karl scavenging fuel is a
recreation of a nother scene for the
pilot all the shots are mirrored and
this little girl Walker that Rick sees
in this scene echoes the one that he put
down in that scene of the pilot and
maybe it's just me but that house number
behind Rick and Judith is 1 0 1 which
was the episode which was the episode
number of The Walking Dead pilot see
this is raw and unedited I normally
would have taken that out anyway we also
see Carol looking over at this flower
drawing on the overpass and I feel like
this could be a callback to when she
told Lizzie to look at the flowers in
season 4 before she killed her Carol's
expression does faintly seem
introspective and haunted here I think
my favorite callback is a line from
negan take a listen
this is great masky something is an
inside joke among fans when they quote
Shane and over the summer the writers
promised that they would use masks you
something as a line of dialogue in
season 8 didn't take too long yes there
was another callback from Jesus who
joked that all I have at the hilltop are
a bunch of books in an old lobster bib
we actually saw that bib hanging in the
background of his place last season now
a lot of you asked why are they shooting
out the windows of the sanctuary this is
actually a callback to season 5 when
Rick brought up the broken window theory
that's the idea in policing where you
can clean up a community by fixing the
broken windows is a small detail that
weirdly reflects society's broader
stability so by targeting windows Rick
is trying to deliver the sanctuary
community a symbolic destabilizing
defeat there's a similar call back when
Rick takes it like a Polaroid picture
damn we can edit this crap out okay so
why does Rick do this on a practical
level Rick could be taking a picture the
Savior's looking week as proved to the
other communities like the trash people
scavengers or Oceanside that Rick or
that negan is weak and it's time to join
our cause but it's also a callback to
past seasons when negan bashes people's
brains and of course the Savior's take a
poll right it's a kind of trophy and in
season 6 Glenn found all those photos
and when he got killed in season 7 a
savior took his photo so Rick could be
doing it here to get inside Meghan's
head all right let's move on this
episode also contain
some interesting cultural influences
that I want to talk about in our segment
under the influence is just getting
better as I mentioned before the
newcomer Abood character spoke the line
may my mercy prevail over my wrath he
said his mother quoted the Quran but
before that he also said whatever you
have of goods spent on the traveler
that's another pair of fries from the
Quran chapter 2 verse 2:15 in the past
The Walking Dead has drawn on Christian
symbolism and morality as a way to
question the violent choices rick has
had to make characters like Gabriel and
Glenn were used as surrogates of that
spirituality now it appears that the
show will be using peaceful messages
from a different faith to temper Rick
during this time of war King Ezekiel
uses a different influence to inspire
his troops he says to quote debod he
today who sheds his blood with me shall
be my brother this is a line from
Shakespeare's Henry the fifth this is
another reminder of Ezekiel's past as a
stage actor henry v was probably a play
he performed in and now he uses that
theatricality to give this commanding
presence now if you zoom in enhance on
Rick's checklist the name in the
location the corner is Pickett field now
it could have been named after George
Pickett a Confederate Major General
during the Civil War he was one of the
guys who led Pickett's charge the
catastrophic Confederate advance at
Gettysburg where their troops were
bombarded with artillery many historians
considered this failed charge to have
been the beginning of the end for the
south of the Civil War so we'll see if
that history has any influence on Rick
here he's not exactly a Pickett figure
his charge this episode was super
victorious and I'm guessing he'll
eventually come out on top of this
all-out war but perhaps Pickett's
failure will haunt Rick in other ways
like the casualty of whomever he's
burying in those shots this episode was
supposedly dedicated to George a
Romero's the Godfather of the zombie
genre behind he was behind night of the
dead and Dawn of the Dead and Day of the
Dead and there were a number of shots of
Walker's looming in the background in
this episode that seemed to be homage as
to Romero's scaled-down horror aesthetic
also the group's tactic to cover the
vehicles with sheet metal which was in
the comics remember could have been
influenced by Zack Snyder's 2004 remake
of Donovan dead now
this episode also seemed to nod to the
original Walking Dead Season 1
showrunner Frank Darabont
there's a shot where Dwight snuffs out
his cigarette signaling Rick's snipers
to take out the savior lookouts
this is very similar to Darabont shot in
his movie The Shawshank Redemption when
the warden also puts out a cigarette to
cue the guard up above to gun someone
down this episode also featured some
interesting audio choices so let's go
over those and my segment huh
hear that okay let's start with this
music that plays in Rick's future dream
this is weird Al's another one rides the
bus it's a 1980 parody of Queens another
one bites the dust Weird Al tweeted that
he was also confused by the show using
this song so what does it mean well I
think the idea of another one biting the
dust could be a clue that this is all
Rick's escapist imagination from yet
another person he loved dying or biting
the dust and the fact that this is a
parody version of the song to me
contributes to this falseness of these
images and maybe I'm stretching here but
maybe to ride the bus on the show could
have a darker meaning after all at the
end of season 6 the characters who rode
the bus were the ones who ended up in
negan's death lineup stay off the bus
stay alive so maybe another one writes
the bus is foreshadowing another
character tragically ending up on the
bloody end of Lucille ok that's the best
I got Weird Al another audio choice I
like came during this 30 second long
take as we wait for the SUV to explode
on the overpass I love how the music
contains a steady tick turning this SUV
into a literal time bomb ok let's talk
briefly about this episode's deeper
meaning it's titled mercy which is a
word that we hear twice as episode when
the traveler and Rick's say that
spiritual verse may my mercy prevail
over my wrath this is a more profound
version of a simpler lesson learned
learned by Rick this episode that this
war isn't about him alone he can't look
at it like a solo campaign to avenge
Glenn and Abraham so even when he has an
almost clear shot of negan at the
sanctuary he decides to retreat with
Gabriel allowing mercy to momentarily
prevail over his wrath so that he can
stick to the plan and get his team a win
but also this decision signals a coming
shift in Rick's worldview
earlier Karl snapped that firing over
someone's head and hoping that they'd
make it isn't enough remember firing
past someone to frighten them is exactly
what negan's men did to Rick at the end
of season six so if Rick wants his new
society to rise above that distrust and
fear he needs to show true mercy okay
let's take a look at the kill count this
episode combining human deaths and
Walker takedowns who was the deadliest
now it's a little hard to tell this
episode we saw lots of saviors getting
gunned down and blown up and from my
count Darrel tops the list
he killed two saviors and at least one
Walker and I suppose we can give him
credit for those other explosions that
kill the other saviors and walkers and
let's not forget Dwight's tire alright
Pete this episode actually kind of
foreshadows Daryl's high numbers this
shot of him taking out this one Savior
is hilarious he takes him off screen and
within seconds he comes back into the
frame with both the guy's gun and his
cigarette this gun had 43 hash marks on
it probably the number of kills that guy
had and you just know Daryl's like you
know what I could probably top that okay
finally let's make some predictions for
next week's episode titled the Damned
the sneak peak released by AMC shows
morgan and the others scoping out these
saviors satellite outpost the site of
rick's first major bloody victory over
the saviors in season six and I don't
know guys I don't feel good about this
after the initial victory I think Rick
and his forces are due for a setback
perhaps as Karma for murdering the
Savior's and their sleep in season six
maybe that's why this episode is called
the Damned
and I don't know if you caught this but
in the opening credits the image used
for Alanna Masterson
Tara's title slide is this station so I
predict something big is about to go
down for her who do you think Rick is
mourning in those teary eyed shots is he
mourning anyone at all and do you think
old man Rick could be a literal future I
want to hear from you in the comments
below and another way you can reach out
to us is on stardust we've actually
started a weekly panel show called the
need to know where we feature viewers
video reactions on stardust app actually
posted my reaction this episode with an
additional detail I noticed you can
download start us by clicking on our
download link in the description below
like and share this video and subscribe
to new rockstars for more analysis of
The Walking Dead and other shows and
movies that you love and if you really
like us you can contribute to us on
patreon big thanks to all of our donor
especially Pony stark tweet me a da vas
with any thoughts or theories you have
or follow new rock stars on Twitter at
new rock stars for updates on her videos
alright thanks for watching bye